[Music]
and urine arson news set it on fire
I set it right here in our soapy Wow
depends on which it's like a
flamethrower through the dick you drink
151 you know let's get into this so bit
by Patriot mark not Patriot they wrote
it with an extra arm yes mmm hey tree
arts at twelve year old boy urinated on
an electrical outlet find an attempt to
set the school on fire yeah well you
know I'd be afraid of peeing on that in
the Amazon River of you pee there's like
some fish that spiky and it swims up
your pee stream into your dick and then
it spikes out like oh [ __ ]
ya know PA almas on river if you I've
never done that yeah there's a there's a
fish that's a little tiny fish
oh yeah that's up your urethra like it
pulls your pee stream into your rethread
and then it spikes out it must be really
strong for it to like swim against
current into your it's much of the way I
pee it goes through your piece be hard
dude what I'd like is I'd Stacey just
met Joe today and surety know it's like
sheep like Rita Michael book she's like
this is her [ __ ] these two and you know
we're not dumb I'm not gonna pee on an
owl and expect to catch on fire you're
gonna if I put gasoline yeah I would
have here on an outlet for fun yeah for
fun that's what this guy was doing but
not to burn the school down I'm pretty
sure he was three-time his age at this
point he doesn't know basic chemistry
that peas gonna put a fire Wow
I'm talking about when I was 12 an
electrical fire yeah oh okay you were
smart all the way better criminal than
this guy well I mean what grade is 12
seven six
that guy's stupid he's stupid yeah all
right past when we go back to the past
and see all the stupid [ __ ] you have
wish
we cut to my inventions actually worked
you guys are probably all skinny like
super skinny Enon outlet to fire oh I
know a sixth grade crime that I did so
like when when it used to be late you
have to fill out these tardy slips right
and it's the same material as a report
card he's you know like the report card
Carbon Copy I least one from high school
it's gray on the back instead of black
yeah and so when I got my report card
all the call [ __ ] a lot of F's on
this [ __ ]
and now how can I change it I'm like oh
yeah the tardy slip is the exact same
material so I'll go to the front of the
office take it put it over my report
card and just make all the FS and turn
them into ace so like that's me at 12:00
I'm like this was Piana outlift was dumb
all right you put it into perspective
I'm convinced we learned how to make
bombs out of fireworks like we would rip
it apart and put it back together with
Snapple bottles and like regular bottles
plastic bottles and then like we would
have them all ready with a wick like out
like this and then we had the bright
idea to jump into the school and then
just start lighting them off and we saw
one locker that was open and then we lit
one and closed the thing oh my god yeah
badass just for doing a pickle opt-in at
the school I was like that's actually
what we used with which was that one is
the one that goes this takes place in
Indiana this 12 year old kid they're
saying that he urinated on this
electrical outlet and he did either
start a small fire or enough smoke
though because it did set off the alarm
not so dumb and then so someone
immediately heard the alarm and rushed
to the restroom because he was in the
restroom and with the fire extinguisher
and put out there's like small fire and
wood you need an electrical outlet in a
school bath I don't know the boys better
charge your phone 2018 Oh down go at the
time like a blow dryer Oh
but for something else like an eraser oh
I don't know um yeah so then they're
saying that the boy was arrested and
accused of criminal recklessness but oh
that's too much
yeah it is it's interesting you could
kill people to fire did he go to jail
just gets expelled or shyness son he was
taken to juvie to the juvie probation
and take offices yeah he's American so
the the fire investigator was saying
that it would not be possible for the
boy to shock himself while he was
urinating because if he was standing up
right but then it's also not likely that
the urine hitting from that angle would
have soaked into the outlet to create
enough heat to cause a fire so the case
remains under investigation
that's how they're reporting this so
they're saying the way he's pinned
electricity can't go up and zap him that
way
Oh cuz he got sad no no if that's the
number one question everyone had didn't
he what do you have guys that went in
there that soap that yeah okay I guess
I'm glad I never had a dick because I
would do some weird experiments like I'd
probably pee on a bunch of [ __ ] like I'd
probably put it in a bunch of place for
sure those are necessary what is the
first thing you do if you had a dick for
a day I probably wanna know that's
amazing
oh you know I like this yeah I thought
you said I already know it I was like
why no one wants to know it's gonna take
more than a day though you gotta warm up
to it because like yeah like as a boy
like you it's it's really sensitive and
then like you gotta kind of like warm up
to it won't look too white your dick
yeah or your dick whatever I jackals are
at the warm up after do my oh no oh
you're stretching
all the boys played with their dick
enough to word that it was ready for ya
you you gotta have a use big room you
want to use it just someone's body that
has a decorated yeah and they primed it
up oh yeah but like a you think it's so
am I like it okay you ready to bust nuts
yeah that person's dick I'll take that
that's too far that's - yeah young dead
person have like a 24 year old
good-looking feeling all the way I don't
think dicks look good looking at all so
just all dicks recruited a dead dick
it's gonna look different though be
alive cuz it's on my live body well they
decided a dick wants it from a dead
person but it already donation logical
within a fantasy world
actually happens people died my dad dick
people get that dick so and it's
different it's different than an
erection I get along after a certain
amount of time I'm not gonna hang out
with people with Dan's ex I'm a [ __ ] you
first thing all you'll see the jurors
grow on a page I have a dead dick I'd
read that I hadn't think before which
was it what did you do with this so I
just remember dreaming that I was in a
restroom and like I was gonna pee but
then all of a sudden I had a dick and I
was like touching it and it was like it
would be like it
I was like whoa this is weird but I
couldn't like feel it though did you
wake up with my imagine KC woke up with
a pz yeah so I was really worried and
then I was weird feelin it between my
legs
- there's also weird they don't know no
I've always had it their whole yeah oh
yes
there's just because I'm so fascinated
even now and I'll see him like like
naked or whatever I'm just like wow like
there's this [ __ ] just dangling get some
pumpkin when it's hot and like yeah you
gotta adjust it you're like I had a
manager that would do that like we would
have morning Huddle's right we would all
stand up and then he'd be like this and
he'd go well I knew what he was doing I
didn't know now you just blew melody no
either no I'm watching back of my room
you know he's like just kind of like
shifting for some reason anyway I don't
know why he shouldn't
oh I've seen that so many times his
buzzer stuck to the side of his leg
sorry fueling it he's peeling it that's
holy you guys some think I'm wearing
like tight skylights so they just like
yeah if you were tighty whities it's
actually even worse box of red if it
separates it but then also y'all you're
nuts feel like having [ __ ] in their
trusty they're you know a little bit
great you guys safe you guys you punch
right like if we got punch I'm like its
it's just like where's the arm
no I [ __ ] love boobs boobs are great
I'd rather have boobs any day I just
play with they're nice playing with them
just like they're easier to get to them
down here for sure I [ __ ] love boobs
those are great
oh yeah what would you guys do this
Tycho was his little boy urinating on
the outlet I'm just gonna slap him [ __ ]
he would don't being barred son if he's
12 not slap the [ __ ] out of them and
teach them a list of other things that
he should be done the school you know
what two or three I'm like okay [ __ ] I
think closer to this yeah what would you
do that I love it he wouldn't do this
[ __ ] but if he was smarter than that
I sold I just don't think the kid was
thinking like I said the school I think
he was probably just pean saw the outlet
and was like yeah more dumb on this
school like why would they have an
outlet use actually I'm I actually want
kids to push the boundaries while I
pretend that I'm mad because I was
reading this book about you want you
want your kids to see and see what like
what can happen in the world and push
the boundaries because when they get
older then they're they're more willing
to take risks with their lives in a good
way but if there are full of rules and
they're good at obeying and then they're
rewarded for like obeying go bangle bank
then like they're gonna be kind of
scared but yeah that's interesting yeah
it's like that um that it's called like
let the boys skate or some [ __ ] like
that hmm yeah so it's like boys are just
going around skating or something is it
mainly boys well because you know like
there's a tendency for boys to do
rebellious [ __ ] because they're more
riskier yeah and what what it is is like
just it helps them kind of challenge
themselves and see what they're capable
of and what will happen if they get in
trouble or whatever and it's kind of
like going back to like when boys needed
to go and kill and protect and hunt and
whatever but that also that adventurous
side that you cultivate will also make
them really like leadership types I was
watching this interview like this Navy
SEAL where like they're like how did you
know you wanted to be a Navy SEAL and
he's just say like never since he was a
kid he just knew he hated rules and then
he found out about an elite profession
where all you're doing is breaking rules
and pulling loopholes of the world and
pulling fast ones and doing whatever the
[ __ ] you want to do he goes [ __ ] that's
what I wanted you're telling me I'm not
supposed to be in this country but I get
to go there on a helicopter and
infiltrate that [ __ ] country and kill
the president of that country you have
to obey within that but it's elite like
its elite privilege that you have to
earn this special right yeah it's like
that you cultivated in the right way
because they still need structure so you
can't make out you can't be too
permissible or else they're gonna [ __ ]
up and go to jail you know hmm
[Music]
[Music]